Brianna relaxed and ready to run this
Super Bowl halftime show welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight K Frey
with Riri in Arizona moments after her
big press conference Kevin miss Robin
Fenty is calm calm cool and collected
listen Michelle I've heard from some
pretty good sources this show is going
to be visually stunning but let's not
get ahead of ourselves the world's media
assembled to hear from Rihanna today but
only E.T caught up with her backstage
[Music]
[Applause]
you have an Oscar nomination and the
show how has this run been for you and
what does it mean you know it really
feels Like A lot's happening all at once
it feels like motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl
I'm still pinching myself really I'm
grateful I'm grateful hello hey everyone
Rihanna hit the stage in her ripped from
the runway a lie a look sharing more
about getting half time ready less than
nine months after baby I have yet to
sleep we were working at the venue all
last night and I kind of just stayed
there today is a really big rehearsal
really important one so that's going to
be crucial for Sunday
when you become a mom there's something
that just happens where you feel like
you could take on the world you can do
anything I haven't been on stage in
seven years
there's something exhilarating about the
challenge of it all it's important for
my son to see that work is always
something that's going to rob you of
time with your child it has to be worth
it there's less than 72 hours to go
re-revealed there's 39 versions of her
set list
the set list was the biggest challenge
the 34 year old has 53 solo singles 14
number ones 25 to hit the top four so
there's lots to choose from but
according to at least two Vegas
oddsmakers Rihanna is favored to open
with diamonds
or Don't Stop the Music
[Music]
you only have 13 minutes that's the
challenge so you're trying to cram
17 years of work into 13 minutes so it's
it's difficult but I think we did a
pretty good job at narrowing it down as
for special guests that could join Riri
we had some guesses ASAP Jay
Pharrell Calvin Harris oh anybody else
and Eminem
[Music]
we need to replay this after the Super
Bowl and see how many she got right
Vegas is verdict bet on either Jay-Z or
her ex
drizzy's collab with Reed more than any
other artist and remember how she and
Jay teamed up for Run This Town well
today Apple music debuted a short film
with that track taking fans back to her
roots in Barbados Babyface have you
picked a side I'm gonna go with Rihanna
the pre-game performers are fired up too
including Babyface Chris Stapleton and
Cheryl Lee Ralph I have you worked on a
unique twist to each one of these iconic
songs
[Music]
we could have a version for people to
understand the great lyrics of this song
to carry on to move on to be to be
forward thinking that's how we approach
the song I'm just gonna try to be as
real as I can with it I'm gonna go out
there and play like I would play it and
that's uh
if that's a Twist then so so be
[Music]